dans la grande région de montréal
plusieurs secteurs sont jugés par
transports québec comme étant à risque
de bourrasques de vent violentes ou
encore de poudrerie soudaine à de
nombreux endroits vous verrez ce genre
de panneau de signalisation
mais est-ce suffisant faut jamais
oublier que ce n'est qu'un phénomène
subi atchan du milieu c'est ben beau
mais a fait une utilité mais limité à
mon avis
rené duval et le coroner qui s'est
penché sur les causes du carambolage qui
a coûté la vie à deux personnes en 2006
sur l'autoroute 40 dans le secteur de
l'assomption il constate des similitudes
frappantes avec l'accident d'hier sur le
dropt 15 à la prairie deux espaces
ouverts exposés au vent il avait à
l'époque recommandé de planter des
conifères pour créer une barrière coupe
vent mais dans ce cas-ci vue l'étroite
bande de terrain entre le fleuve et la
route il pencherait pour une autre
option est la seule discussion que je
vois c'est un mur mur mais auxerre et
végétales clôture ou encore mûr brise
vent les solutions sont nombreuses pour
éviter la formation soudaine de murs de
poudrerie
mais avant se précipiter pour faire un
choix il faut faire des tests explique
cet expert il faut aussi mule évidemment
les fêtes c'est brice grand lot des
problèmes en des conditions alors ça
peut être simulé par des modèles
mathématiques des modèles informatiques
et aussi en soufflerie
donc on peut mettre des maquettes assez
grande échelle pour simuler l'effet des
systèmes qu'on veut implanter sur
l'enneigement d'une autoroute sur les
bourrasques sur les turbulences
installer une barrière végétale et moins
cher et permet de bloquer une partie du
vent bâtir un mur peut sembler la
solution idéale puisqu'il est moins
perméable et attention il peut devenir
contre-productif si on met un mur par
exemple mur qui serait plaint la neige
va se retrouvent retrouver en arrière on
va avoir un phénomène de turbulence
si on n'a pas suffisamment de distance
on va créer des lames de neige qui vont
se retrouver sur la sur la route
donc oui on va empêcher d'avoir une
mauvaise visibilité
mais on va se retrouver avec un problème
de l'âme de neige et parfois des
solutions toutes simples peuvent
permettre d'éviter un épisode de
poudrerie par exemple s'assurer que les
déneigeuses ne crie pas dedans neige
trop haut ce qui facilite l'envol de la
neige et perturbent la visibilité il si
fanny but serbe et nicole radio canada
montréal